well we've learned about new evidence
implicating the crown prince CBS News
can confirm that the CIA has
intelligence that substantiates an
assessment that Mohammed bin Salman
ordered the killing a bipartisan group
of US lawmakers is now calling for
strong action against the Saudi
leadership Holly Williams is the only
network correspondent in the Saudi
capital Riyadh Holly good morning good
morning here in Saudi Arabia the
country's leaders seem to be watching
and waiting to see what President Trump
does next the president is under
pressure from Congress and if he now
comes out and confirms that US
intelligence believes that Crown Prince
Mohammed bin Salman was behind the
killing of Jamal [ __ ] that could be
catastrophic for the current regime here
remember Saudi Arabia first denied it
knew anything about Jamal hisagi
disappearance then it finally admitted
he died inside the Saudi consulate in
Istanbul it claimed in a fist fight then
last week there was a new version of
events from the prosecutor here who said
a team was sent to Turkey to bring her
shoulder to Saudi Arabia by force if
necessary but then a team leader decided
to kill him with a lethal injection we
were at a press conference here on
Thursday where the Saudi foreign
minister said the crown prince had been
exonerated of any involvement 11 people
have now been indicted here five of them
could face the death penalty
those men presumably know the truth
including perhaps who ultimately gave
the order to kill Jamal [ __ ] and the
fear is they could be put to death
before they have a chance to tell the
outside world what happened
bianna Polly Williams in Saudi Arabia so
important to have you there thank you